what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and we're still covering
everything that happened at san diego
comic con this past weekend because so
much was revealed for marvel studios's
hall h panel yesterday we went over the
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 trailer
footage that was shown during hall h and
today we are going to be going over the
ant-man and the wasp quantum mania
footage that was shown that includes
kang the conqueror and even showed
ant-man and king actually talking to
each other and kang actually mentioned
the avengers by name of course kang is
about to have his own movie where he is
going to be the big bad of not just
ant-man the wasp and stature but all of
the avengers together in avengers the
king dynasty and i'm guessing that kang
probably survives through that and ends
up in secret wars as well so if you want
to stay updated on all things msu be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos let's dive
into this footage that was shown so this
footage has one of the best lines from a
villain that i have ever heard it
literally sends chills down my spine
just reading it i can't wait to watch it
when the official trailer comes out and
it's an interaction between king and
ant-man which we'll get to in just a bit
but the trailer starts off with scotland
reading an excerpt from his book to a
crowd he hasn't been in action in a
while then he gets a call from his phone
and it's actually jail calling he picks
up his daughter cassie lange from prison
and he wants to help her but doesn't
want her wasting her life it's here
where he kind of gives her a pep talk
and reminds her that he saved the world
as an avenger but it's here where hank
pym actually calls him out for
constantly talking about that and
bringing it up then hope and janet also
pile on top of it pretty much reminding
him the same thing perhaps the little
bit of fame is getting to ant-man's head
here but here's where it gets just so
good it cuts to kang speaking to scott
lang and he says you're an interesting
man scotland and then he actually points
out how many years he missed because he
was trapped inside of the quantum realm
he says you've lost a lot of time but
time it isn't what you think it's not a
straight line then it cuts the footage
of something in a lab exploding and then
all of a sudden they all start to get
sucked into the quantum realm they all
end up in another world navigating it in
new suits as bill murray's krylar shows
up who happens to know janet because
remember janet was stuck in the quantum
realm for a very long time and just the
fact that we have bill freaking murray
in the mcu just makes me so dang excited
i love him so much
and murray
i had to get that out but then we cut
back to kang talking to scott lang and
he says everything you are holding on to
everything you call life i know how it
ends but scott maybe with some of that
ego i was talking about tells king that
he's made a big mistake because he is an
avenger and kang asks him in disbelief
you're an avenger and then he ponders to
scott and says have i killed you before
and this has to be one of the coolest
lines a villain has ever said to a hero
before now let's break down this trailer
footage and also talk about why kang
specifically is interested in ant-man
and modoc they actually specifically
showed one shot of modok in this trailer
he had no lines or dialect whatsoever
but he was shown so we'll talk about
that as well so we start off in this
footage with ant-man reading to people
and he is kind of famous now he has
written a book he's been an avenger he's
helped save the world and he
consistently reminds it seems like his
daughter but also a lot of other people
as well that he saved the world and it
seems like hank hope and janet are all
kind of getting tired of that but hey
it's understandable he used to be a
criminal and now all of a sudden he's
saving the world he's writing books he's
reading that book to a bunch of people
he's pretty famous now ant-man is kind
of living his best life however his
daughter seems to be getting into some
trouble also if you are not aware they
have replaced the original actress who
played scotland's daughter cassie lang
with catherine newton this is of course
because cassie lang in the comics is
actually the hero stature so it looks
like they found an actress that is a
little bit older and more in line with
how they view that character but some
time will have passed as well so it'll
just be like she's grown up now but
scott lang ant-man has caught the
attention of king the conqueror for some
reason and we can only assume that it's
connected to the quantum realm
especially since this movie is titled
quantum mania and it's good to know that
ant-man and the rest of the gang seems
to get sucked into the quantum realm
pretty early on in the movie thanks to
this trailer description because if you
title a movie quantum mania you better
spend a lot of time in the quantum realm
now kang is the master of time the
conqueror of time and as we learned from
loki he actually started the multiversal
war him and all of his different
variants then one of his variants he who
remains harnessed the power of eliath
and he ended the multiversal war and
created one timeline however at the end
of loki loki and silvi ended that and
the multiverse is now thrown into chaos
again so we are getting a bunch of
different kang variants but it seems
like this king seems to specifically be
from our universe or has mastered or
conquered a lot of other universes as
well this is clearly evident based off
of what he says he explains that time is
not a straight line and we actually
learned this and it was demonstrated
during loki so this kang clearly knows
how time works and he's run into
avengers before which is why he's kind
of taken back when scott says he's an
avenger and he responds with you're an
avenger have i killed you before so
clearly he has dominated the avengers
before in other timelines and also
remember that king can exist in the past
in the present and the future he can go
wherever he wants in time which makes
him extremely dangerous he can pretty
much control the events of the world and
i'm assuming that this is why ant-man
has the attention of kang kang clearly
knows that scott was trapped inside of
the quantum realm perhaps kang was in
the quantum realm as well and even
observed ant-man but if he knows this
then he knows that ant-man is the one
who kind of got the avengers to be able
to time travel and that could have
actually thrown off king's plans if kang
knows all he knew thanos was going to
eliminate half of the universe and since
we've learned from loki that pretty much
all of the events kang lets happen we
can assume that kang let thanos snap
away half of the universe that was a
part of his plan however what might not
have been a part of his plan was the
avengers going back in time collecting
infinity stones and bringing half of the
universe back also when the avengers
went back in time they probably did
create branch timelines despite
returning the stones to the exact point
in time i mean after all captain america
did stay back in time with peggy carter
and the entire timeline that 2012's
thanos gamora nebula were in is
completely thrown off now and kang
doesn't just rule one universe he rules
multiple universes remember that's the
whole goal of kang to conquer to conquer
the entire multiverse not just one
universe but the entire multiverse so
this probably screwed up a lot of king's
plans and his other universes and it all
stems from ant-man now he might not know
that ant-man is an avenger he might
think that he's just the one that kind
of told the avengers about the quantum
realm either way i definitely think kang
wants ant-man because of what he did in
regards to time travel and i don't know
if you've seen jonathan mages recently
but the dude is jack just take a look at
this picture you can follow me on
instagram and twitter for live updates
like this as well and last but not least
modok was in the footage for ant-man and
the wasp quantum mania there was just
one single shot of him but it looks like
he's going to be a little bit different
than we're used to it appears that the
character is going to be fully robotic
apparently there is still going to be
the visual of a massive face but instead
there's going to be the integration of a
large golden face with crimson red eyes
all of which are apparently going to be
mechanical so this could kind of be like
ultron but i'm assuming that at one
point in time modoc had let's say a
human brain he might have just moved his
brain from his original human body to a
mechanical body that way it could be
better protected and as of right now
there's no word on who could be playing
modok pat and oswalt played him in the
hulu series and i'd love to see him play
him in the mcu but no word as of yet
there was a rumor a long time ago that
jim carrey might possibly play modok but
we have not heard anything official
about that or even a rumor about that in
a very long time but go ahead and let me
know what you think about the footage
description for ant-man and the wasp and
what do you think about the new design
of modoc let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe to stay up
to date with all things mcu you can
follow me on instagram and twitter for
live updates and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof
you